checking average
and the and the exam. Otherwise, you'll
have too much gaming because you do
really well in the first two quizzes.
There's no point taking the third quiz,
right? Well, I was
saying that.
No, but if you missed one of the
quizzes, I said there's a you lose the
average. But if you took all three
quizzes and I average just across the
quizzes you did, let's say you got
perfect scores in the first two quizzes,
you just take the third quiz and just
now you don't care. I want to make sure
that you always care about the quiz you
take because there is some residual
effect of what will I do on the final.
Okay, folks. I hope you've had a chance
to pick up your quizzes. If not, they
are still in alphabetical order when I
left. Come down. I hope they're still in
alphabetical order when I go up. So,
please leave them in alphabetical order.
Otherwise, I know I'll have to resort
them and tomorrow I'm leaving for San
Diego. So, I won't even be able to
resort them if you screw it up over the
weekend. But they will stay out probably
for 10 days. Let me take the property
out. They will stay out for 10 days. You
know what happens in 10
days? There'll be a third quiz in which
case I have to take the second. I can't
throw them out legally for a year after
you take this class. you know that NYU
doesn't allow you to, but I actually
throw them out the day after the class
is done. What are they going to do? Fire
me or whatever they decide to do. But if
you don't want your quiz, I don't want
it either. So, I will hold on to till
the end of the class, but I think it is
a good idea for you to at least pick up
your second quiz. There are about a
hundred unclaimed first
quizzes. 100. One out of three people
thinks that if you don't see something,
it doesn't
exist. But it does, right? So, might as
well pick it up, even if it's bad news,
and get it out of the way. I thought
that this was a easy quiz because I, if
you know why, because after last
Thursday and Friday, I thought you
needed a break. But now that the market
is up, I think I'll up my auntie for the
third quiz and hit you with a really
difficult one because you'd be so let's
start this class talk about pricing. You
have the ammunition now to be able to do
pricing. So let's see if we're the the
last few sessions have kind of stuck. I
told you I was in Latin America last
week. I was in Chile and then I was in
Argentina. Let me reframe this question
using Chile and Argentina as my
examples. Let's suppose I look at the P
ratio for Chile and the P ratio for
Argentina. P ratio for Argentina is much
lower than the P ratio for Chile. It
makes Argentine stocks cheap, right? But
what else explains why Argentina has a
lower PE ratio than Chile?
Argentina. In Latin America, Chile has
always been the outlier, the safest
country in a continent full of very
risky
countries. So, Chile is safer than
Argentina. Other things remaining equal.
What does that mean? Less risk should
push up your P ratio. So, Venezuela and
Argentina will have the lowest P ratios.
I think you know Venezuela trades at six
times earnings, five times earnings.
Argentina trades at seven times
earnings, but part of that is risk. And
to the extent that the risk goes away, P
ratio should rise. Let's try a second
one. It's an extension of what we did a
couple of sessions ago when I looked at
the earnings to price ratio for the S&P
500. Okay, P ratio right now, even I was
going to say even if you count what
happened last week or because by the if
you look at what happened this
afternoon, we might be back to where we
were before last week. So God only knows
where we are. But it's the PE ratio is
been higher for the S&P 500 for the last
few years. So let me list out it's it
might mean that stocks are overpriced,
but let me list out possible
explanations that are not, you know,
that have nothing to do with it being
overpriced. No, especially in 2019 2021
when you saw PE ratios at
highs, risk-free rates were at historic
lows. Can that explain why PE ratios
should be higher?
lower interest rates, higher PE ratios.
So for a decade, we had higher P ratios
and you could say it's a risk-free rate.
That's no longer the case anymore,
right? Could it be that the equity risk
premium is much higher than it has been
historically? Equity risk premiums get
higher, the index should actually go in
the other direction, right? Equity risks
being lower can explain but not higher.
Could it be the return equity has
increased over time? is does that play
into your PE ratio? Higher return equity
should push up P ratio. So that could be
a good reason. Could it be that the
expected growth rate is going to be
higher in earnings in the future? I'm
not saying any of these explain it away.
But when you look at the P ratio for the
market, you have to control for interest
rates, you have to control for return
equity, you have to control for risk
premiums, and you have to control what
the growth is before you decide stocks
are overpriced or underpriced.
And my final question is about PEG
ratios and PEG ratios basically and what
you're assuming when you use PEG ratios.
So let's say company A has a PE ratio of
20 and expected growth rate of 10% a
year. Company B has a PE ratio of 10 and
an expected growth rate of 5% a year for
the next month. If I compute PEG ratios
these two
companies, I'll get exactly the same PEG
ratio, two for each company, right?
20ide by 10, 10 divided by five.
So I could conclude that company AB is
cheaper because it has the lower P.
Company A is cheaper because the highest
higher expected growth. Or if I believe
PEG ratios that they're both correctly
priced or priced
similarly. But is that true though that
the PEG ratio is the same? the two
stocks are priced correct because they
were not and which means as your growth
doubles your P might not double you know
problem with PEG ratios that's a linear
assumptions about growth we talked about
how as PEG ratio as growth changes the P
ratio can change this proportionally so
what we're going to do today is com look
go through a series of other pricing
multiples and by now you know the script
I'm going to go back to an intrinsic
value
model and I'm going to use the intrinsic
value model to try to address what are
the variables that drive a multiple and
then use that to ask what questions
about a company being cheap or
expensive. So I left you with EV tabida
multiples and I said EV tabida multiples
basically are determined by a bunch of
variables and here are the variables the
cost to capital growth and reinvestment
rate which you should see in any
enterprise value multiple and the tax
rate why does tax rate matter when you
look at EV to Ebida multiples because
EIDA is before
taxes and I ask you to think about a
hypothetical where what if you're
looking at a country where the tax rate
is 100% an absurd example But let's say
you have a country where they take all
your earnings away. What multiple of
EIDA should you pay in that country?
Should be zero, right? You're going to
get nothing anyway. So when you look at
EIDA multiples, you always have to ask
about tax rate. So I'm going to go back
and set up a hypothetical example where
here's what I have. I have a company
with a tax rate of 36%. Capex is 30% of
EIDA. Depreciation is 20% of EIDA. So
their net capex is 10% of EIDA. So
that's what they're reinvesting. Their
cost of capital is 10%. Let's ignore
working capital requirements to keep
things simple. I'm going to compute the
EV to EIDA multiple a fair intrinsic EV
to EBIDA multiple assuming the company's
in stable growth growing 5% a year. So
all I've done is plugged in the numbers.
Tax rate of 36% 10% cost of capital 5%
growth rate. And what I get as my
intrinsic EV to Ebida for this company
is 8.24 24 times epida. Given those
numbers, I would expect this company to
trade at 8. As I said, if all you do is
this equation, it's kind of pointless.
You'd have got the same value with a
discounted cash flow model. But the nice
thing about these hypothetical examples
is I can change one variable at a time,
which you can't do in the in the real
world, right? Because everything in a
company is connected. So the first thing
I did was I changed the tax rate from 36
to 30 to 20 to 10 to 0%. or also
increasing it to 50%. No surprise here
as my tax rate goes from 0 to 50% the EV
to Abida multiple a fair number to pay
goes from six 14 times ABIDA to less
than six times AIDA same company same
numbers different saying when would I
ever get tax rates that different let's
say you're the airline analyst for
Europe and within your sector you have
all of the airlines of Europe including
Ryionaire the Irish airline and Lufansza
which is the German airline
Given that graph, if you're not aware of
it, which which of these companies is
going to look cheap and which one's
going to look
expensive? You're looking for low EVA.
You're going to find low EVA. Which
company is going to have the low EV
debit? I'm
sorry. Try again. 50.
Because if you have a high tax rate, so
you're going to end up with the with the
airlines and countries with high tax
rates look cheap because they'll trade
low. Ryan Air is going to look expensive
and you say that's a really expensive
airline until you factor in that the
Irish tax rate is only 12%. So if you're
comparing across countries, companies
across countries with different tax
rates. Same thing is true in Southeast
Asia. You have Indonesian companies,
Thai companies, basically, you know, all
competing for the same investor base.
You got to control for differences in
tax rates. Yes.
I'll I'll tell you something about
pricing. There is no right, there's no
better or worse as long as you control
for differences. I have no problem with
you using EB debit as long controlling
for difference in tax rates is pretty
trivial to do, right? But you do have to
remember to do it with price earnings
ratio. It's true you don't have to
control for difference in tax rates, but
you you invite other problems, right?
These are companies in different
countries. They have accounting
standards that vary. Earnings per share
is going to be much more affected by
those choice choices than something
further up the income
statement. Let's talk about finally
about revenue multiples. Remind me again
why we look use revenue multiples.
First is desperation, right? This is the
only number that's positive. What else
is good about
revenues? Been complaining about
accounting all this time, right? What's
a number that accountants have the least
influence over? It's revenues. Anytime
the further down the income statement
you go, the more you worry about
accounting effects. Earnings per share
is the worst. Re even revenues, you
still have some mild discretionary
choice, especially when you have
revenues over multiple years. But
revenues so revenue multiples are here
to stay. Let's see what drives a revenue
multiple. There are two variants that
you would see of the revenue multiple.
Price to sales where you take market cap
and divide by revenues which we already
said is an inconsistent multiple because
numerator is an equity value or the more
consistent version which is enterprise
value to sales. The biggest selling
point is you can compute them for pretty
much every company if your business has
revenues.
What kinds of businesses don't have
revenues? Well, but let's go even on
established companies. There's a whole
bunch of in fact a very big sector where
you will not see a revenue line item.
Yes, it's right. Biotech eventually have
revenues, right? Amjen has revenues. So
then that's again young companies might
not. But this is even mature companies
and businesses. Try
banks. You know what? You look for a
revenue item. Banks has no such thing.
There'll be interest income minus
interest expense. Financial service
companies don't have revenues. That's
why when you look at my industry
averages, I don't report industrial
averages for investment banks,
commercial bank. It's not like they
don't make money, but there's nothing to
scale it to in terms of revenues. But if
your business is revenues, which is the
rest of the market, you can compute
revenue multiples. You're not going to
lose companies which are money losing or
so you get the entire sample in. So I'm
before I show you the page that tells
you what the drivers of revenue
multiples are. I want somebody to guess
every multiple as a companion variable.
You know what I mean by a companion
variable? It's a one number you'd like
to know before you use that multiple.
I'll give you a preview with price
earnings ratio. When I tell you a stock
has a low PE, the one question you
should ask, what kind of growth rate
does it have? Most of the time when you
have a low P, it's going to go with a
low growth rate. So you're looking for
is that the reason with price to book,
what do you think the companion variable
is? What's the one number you'd like to
know? The return on equity, right? Most
low price to book stocks have low
returns and
equity. With revenue multiples, what's
that one question? So let's say I'm a
broker and say this company is trading
at one quarter revenues. What did it
like?
No, you're close. But there's something
even more direct that will usually tell
you why the company is trading at a low
multiple of
revenues. It's exactly right. Right. If
you have low margins, you will trade at
a low multiple of revenues. Okay. But
revenue multiples, a key driver is
profit margins. What kinds of businesses
have low margins? First is bad companies
have low margins. But there are some
really good companies with low margins
as well. Who's doing Costco? Somebody in
the class. I think at least two people
are doing Costco. Trust me, I'm not
going to ask you a deep question. No,
nobody's doing Costco. Okay. But you're
familiar with Costco, right? Been a
success story in brick and mortar
retail. A very unusual success story
because the rest of brick and mortar
retail has kind of melted down. We can
talk about what's allowed Costco to not
just survive but
prosper but it trades at a low multiple
of revenues. In fact, if you rank it
across companies, it's actually below
the median for typical
retailers. Why is
that? What's a Costco
model? At low prices, they're a low
margin, high turnover company. Walmart
is the same way. It doesn't mean they're
bad companies. It means that they'll
trade at low multiples of revenues, but
they hope to get really, really, really
high revenues. So, low multiple of a
really high revenue is better than a
high multiple of very little in
revenues. I'm going to give you a simple
way in which you can always get the
companion variable. If I give you a
multiple, all you need to do is take
earnings and divide it by the
denominator of your multiple and you'll
get the companion variable. The earnings
you use will depend on whether I'm an
equity multiple or you have no idea what
I'm talking about. Right? Let's try this
price to book
ratio. What is it? An equity multiple or
enterprise value multiple. An equity
multiple. Right? So what's the earnings
that goes with equity? Net income. You
divide net income by book value of
equity. What do you get? Return equity.
If I use one of those mis, you know,
misguided people use price to sales.
What's the companion variable going to
be? What's take net income divide by
sales and what do you get when you
divide net income by sales? Net
margin. You're saying it doesn't work
with price earnings ratio. If I take
price earnings ratio, saying dividing
net income by net income gives me one.
But net income in the future divide by
net income today is expected growth in
net income. works with PE as well. You
ready to try this with enterprise value
multiples? Enterprise value to invested
capital. Let's try it out. What's the
measure of earnings that goes with
enterprise value? EBIT. So, and what's
EBIT divided by invested
capital? It's return on capital. EV to
invest. EV to
sales. I'm going to stay with you. EBIT
divided by sales is operating margin.
It's like magical, right? You take
whatever multiple, you take the measure
of earnings that goes with it, divide by
the
denominator. So try it out on some
foreign multiple. It's amazing how you
can get that one question you want
answered before. So let's prove this
algebraically. Again, don't get thrown
off by the by the number of terms in the
equation. This is a two-stage enterprise
value model. I've computed it in terms
of EV to sales by dividing both sides by
sales. And there's the magic after tax
operating margin. High margin companies
will trade at high multiples of
revenues. Low margin companies will
trade at low multiples of revenues. It's
no reflection. Unlike other multiples,
you think about low numbers as as a bad
thing. The company with revenue
multiples, you got to be very careful
because they capture only one half the
equation.
So EB to sales is driven by reinvestment
rate, cost to capital, growth rate.
Those are always a constant after tax
operating margin is that companion
variable. So if you can make a table of
six or seven or eight commonly used
multiples, come up with that companion
variable and those other var because
those are the questions you need to ask
to answer is that a good is that a cheap
stock or is that a stock that just
deserves to be
cheap. How many of you are mark is I
don't even know how majors work in the
undergraduate business school. Can you
be a marketing
major? Yeah. Are there any marketing
majors in this room? Nobody's misguided
enough to do that. But in marketing, of
course, brand name is a big deal, right?
And in
marketing, welcome. I'm sorry. I forgot
to enter your names in the visitors
list, but you managed to get into the
into the building anyway,
right? We have some high school
visitors, so be nice to
them. So, if you think about the value
of brand name early on, what did I say
about brand name? What does brand name
give
you? It gives you pricing power, right?
Not just resilience, which is stability,
higher margins. So I'm going to use that
to capture the value of a brand name
using EV to sales rate. EV to sales
ratio we said are driven by brand name.
Maybe looking at revenue multiples for
companies is going to tell me which
companies have more valuable brand
names. So if my hypothesis right what
should you expect to see margin brand
name companies should trade at much
higher multiples of revenues than no
margin companies because of the
difference in brand name. I know it
sounds abstract but let me use an actual
example. about 20 years ago got a call
from a student of mine is pretty high up
in
Coca-Cola management team and he said
and Coca-Cola is a company that's
obsessed with branding for a long time
it was the most valuable brand name in
the world before the advent of
technology
companies he calls me and said can you
come to Atlanta and talk to our top
management team about brand name they're
obsessed about how much it's
worth so I said okay moment of weakness
Because New York to Atlantis is
incredibly expensive flight. I don't
know why. They just, you know, I guess
it's a cap to market for I know Delta,
whoever flies there. Show up in Atlanta.
Show up at Coca-Cola headquarters. I
carried a can of Pepsi in with me.
Sometimes it's good to keep people off
balance. So they had the top management
team gathered
together and I said, "No." And I went
through an intrinsic valuation of
Coca-Cola. The traditional intrinsic
valuation, free cash for the cost of
capital, return capital. The value that
I got for Coca-Cola based on a
traditional intrinsic value was about
$80 billion. 79.6
billion. So I finished my valuation
expecting
applause. This guy in the front row puts
up his hand. You forgot something very
important. What a beverage, a geography.
What? So I said, what did I forget? He
said, "You forgot the fact that
Coca-Cola is the most valuable brand
name in the
world." I said, "So?" He said, "You
should be adding a premium to that 80
billion." I said, "How much of a
premium?" He said, "At least
20%." I said, "Why?" He said, "Because
that's what we do at Coca-Cola is when
we buy brandame companies, we value them
and then we add 20%."
He said, "Just because you do stupid
things doesn't mean I have to do stupid
things as well." He said, "Don't you
think our brand name is value?" I said,
"Probably the only thing in this
building of any
value." What else is in that building?
You know, the syrup, who
cares? The management team chat GPT
could run Coca-Cola probably better than
existing management can. I didn't say
that there because there was no chat
GPT. That's what I was thinking.
He said, "Why aren't you adding a
premium?" You know what my answer
was? It's already in there. He said,
"Where?" I said, "Why do you think you
have
15.57% margins? Do you think it's the
taste? You think it's a red can?" It's
because you have a brand name. Why do
you think returns in capital 21%.
Because you have a brand name. Even your
cost of debt. You walk into a bank in
Atlanta and say we're Coca-Cola. Do you
think your cost of debt is affected?
Absolutely. Every number in your
valuation already reflects your brand
name. He said I don't believe you. This
is what happens when you argue with
marketing people. But I came
prepared and I got lucky. I found a
company called CO coot. It's a Canadian
company that sells almost as many cans
of sodas as Coca-Cola does in the US.
You've never heard of it, right? You
know why? Because they allow
supermarkets to put their own brand
names. They allow you to put a generic
brand name on there. They're a generic
soda company. So, here's the question
asked. If tomorrow we all woke up with
selective
amnesia and the only things we didn't
recognize were the words Coca-Cola and
that red can, what would happen? In
other words, I would say, what if I
turned off the brand name? How much
you'd become a generic sort of company,
right? And if you're a generic sort of
company, you're going to have generic
soda company margins, 5.28%. You have
generic sort of company margins. You
have generic sort of company returns on
capital 7%. Gener it ripples through all
the way. It affects your return capital,
your growth rate and it translates to a
value of 15.4
billion. You want me to give you a brand
name premium? I just did. In fact, you
take the difference between those two
numbers. I'm giving you 64.4 billion.
80% of your value as a company is coming
from your brand name. You don't think
it's enough? Tell me
why. But your value is already in there.
You see why this works well for
Coca-Cola but might not work well for an
apple? What is it about Coca-Cola that
makes brand name so easy to
isolate?
Yes. Fact. It's the only competitive
advantage here. Right. As contrast with
Apple. Apple has some brand name. What
else goes into an Apple
Premium? The operating system is
different. There's a styling effect that
John and I have put in
there. There are but the more
competitive advantages you have, the
more difficult it becomes to separate
them out. Right? We tried with
Birkenstock, but that's because I made
those artificial lines. when you have a
single competitive advantage, it's easy
to say this is where it comes from and
value the competitive advantage. And
that's what we've done here. So when you
look at revenue multiples across
companies, one simple way to see if your
company is a brandame company is to see
if it trades at a premium above the
typical revenue multiple for that
sector. So I won't punish you anymore by
taking you through any more multiples,
but by now you see the script, right? If
you have an equity multiple, go back to
the simplest equity valuation model, a
dividend discount model. With the
algebra, you can tell me what drives a
price earnings ratio, price to book,
price peg ratio, price to sales. At
least you're getting a sense of what
drives that multiple. If you have an
enterprise value multiple, go back to
the simplest enterprise value mult model
you can think of. And with the algebra
you can tell me what drives pretty much
any
multiple precal firm multiple EIDA
multiple EBIT multiple revenue multiple
why we're doing it because the essence
of pricing is to know what to control
for what questions to ask and this will
give you a way of determining what those
variables should
be. I wanted to take a multiple like
enterprise value to subscriber.
If I took Netflix,
Spotify, Disney Plus, Disney Plus is
tougher because Disney is part of a
company. But let's take Enterp, you
know, Netflix versus Spotify. You take
the enterprise value of the company,
divide by the number of subscribers each
one has. I haven't even looked at the
numbers, but there will you'll get
different numbers. What are the
questions you would ask if you're
looking at enterprise value to
subscriber? You know, any any questions
you might have? Let's say I know now
Netflix has a higher
multiple no value per subscriber.
I want to understand what exactly drives
those subscribers, the value of a
subscriber, right? So, let's let's boil
down on that. What is it that
makes that drives the value of a
subscriber? Look at a Netflix sticky and
Before we do that, first we start with
what do you charge, right? So, you're
looking to see what does Netflix charge,
what does Spotify charge, and if Netflix
charge a lot more per month, that's a
starting point. I have both. I don't
even listen to Spotify, but my family
does. I pay roughly the same. So it's
not the level. What else?
So basically that's going to come in and
whether that content scales up with the
number of subscribers if you have
economies of scale. Okay. Let's stay on
a subscriber though. We know how much
how Netflix makes money. It makes it per
subscriber.
Cost. It's the acquisition cost of your
growing growth. How much growth is
there? How many? We're asking the right
questions and that's what pricing should
be about. And don't forget one final
question. What's your churn rate? You
know what a churn rate is subscription
model? It's what percentage of your
subscribers do you lose every year?
Businesses with high churn rate should
have much lower value per subscriber
than business with low churn rates.
That's essentially what pricing is all
about is asking the right questions. I
mean, I've heard, you know, I've seen
people more often than not in the last
decade and they conclude that Tesla's
overvalued. Lots of good reason to
conclude that that's the case. But the
way they do it is they take the
enterprise value for Tesla, divide by
the number of cars sold, and they
compare it to the enterprise value to
car sold for GM or Chrysler or
Volkswagen or Toyota. And guess when
which which one always looks cheaper?
All the legacy auto companies all look
cheap relative to
Tesla which is you know neither here nor
there. It could be because Tesla is
overvalued but it could also be there's
a no growth in a legacy company. In fact
you might looking be looking at
shrinking businesses but shrinking
margins. We have to ask the right
questions before use a pricing to make
that
judgment. So define describe analyze.
Let's get to the apply stage. For those
of you who sent me your DCFs, I'm still
working. I have like 123 left and I'm
going to try to get them out today and
tomorrow.
Okay? But if you got your DCF back and
it looks pretty close to done and many
of you it was pretty close to done, you
got to check, right? Twothirds of your
project is done. There's one more agenda
item that you really have to complete,
which is you have to price your company.
What does that involve? You got to find
first a pure group and you have to pick
a multiple and then you got to compare
across these companies. But a big part
of that is finding a peer group. So I
want to talk a little bit about how do
we come up with that peer group? What
are the companies that you want to put
into that peer group? I mean in theory
you'd like companies just like yours,
right? Similar cash flow, similar
growth, similar risk. Doesn't even have
to be in the same business, but you're
looking for companies similar to yours.
And then even after you get those
companies, you got to kind of find a way
to control for differences across those
companies. So let's take that first
part. How do you find a peer group? And
I'll give you the fundamental choice you
face. And I will let you kind of work
out which of those you know pathways
you're going to take. When you look for
a peer group for your company, you can
look for companies just like your
company. varies in terms of size, in
terms of geography, in terms of what you
do and end up with a smaller sample of
companies just like yours. You might
have only two or three companies if
you're
lucky. Or you can define companies more
broadly and bring in a much larger
sample of companies but with big
differences in growth and risk and cash
flows. Which is better? Find companies
just like your small sample. Of course,
you say, "I'd like a large sample of
companies just like mine." But, you
know, that's not going to often be the
case. If you can do that, find a middle
ground. You set some limits on how
different growth and all these other
fundamentals can be and then you look at
companies in that range. Okay. But
before you do a middle ground, do you
also need to decide how you're going to
use those companies? Because once you
get that pure group, there are there are
different ways and you can do this
analysis, right? One is you could try to
do direct comparisons. You want to do a
direct comparison, you want the
companies to be very very similar.
Through much of the 20th century, equity
research analysts in the US who followed
the auto sector, you know how many
companies they
tracked? Three companies, GM, Ford, and
Chrysler. They didn't even bring in
foreign companies. GM, Ford, and
Chrysler. They in fact of those three,
GM and Ford were often the only two that
they compared. They compared GM to Ford.
They said GM looks cheap relative to
Ford or Ford looks cheap relative to
GM. It's a direct comparison. You want
the companies to be very very similar
when you do that. If you have four or
five or six companies, you might not be
doing a direct comparison, but you might
be comparing the companies and then
telling a story and hoping the story
kind of captures the difference. So you
might say, look, I'm comparing five
companies. My company has a higher
multiple of earnings than these other
companies, but has higher growth, so
it's okay. So again, you still want
companies just like yours on every other
dimension. If your plan in pricing is to
just tell stories or do direct
comparisons, you want your sample size
to be small and look just like your
company. So if you're valuing Bajage
Auto, an Indian automobile company, you
know what you're going who you're going
to look at? Other Indian automobile
companies. There aren't that many, but
you're hoping they're all Indian.
They're all automobile companies. They
sell into the same market. And you
probably don't want to include Tata
Motors in the mix. Why?
because you have the Jaguar Land Rover
thing in the side. So, you're going to
try to make things because you want to
keep those comparisons simple, but I'm
going to open the door to a different
way of controlling for multiples. One is
you try to take the companion variable
and you try to bring it into the
multiple. That's what peg ratio is
trying to do, right? Price earnings, the
big companion. It's a dangerous game to
play because of that linearity
assumption. But some people, but I'm
going to suggest a different way of
controlling for multiples that falls
back on your
statistics. Remember the multiple
regression we ran across when you looked
up P ratios across countries? You're
going to see me use that repeatedly in
the next few examples to try to control
for differences because that's what
multiple regressions were designed to
do. Bring in the variables you're
worried about and control for those
differences.
So you can relax now because I'm going
to play the role of a naive equity
research analyst. I'm going to put buy
recommendations and I want you to shoot
them down. You have the ammunition now
to shoot them down. Ready? So here's my
first try. I am the beverage analyst and
this is my
sector and I'm going to put by
recommendations in three companies in
the sector.
Andre wine. Do you you know what they
make? Champ champagne that's so cheap
that watching a commercial for it I
think can give you a headache. Usually
see it only around Christmas time. Todd
Hunter. I have no idea what they make.
Probably cheap
liquor. And Hansen, my three buys. I
told you I was a naive analyst. Why did
they pick those three, Sophia? What is
it that those three companies share?
all have P ratios less than 10. I picked
the three companies with the lowest P
ratio. I'm lazy. Not only am I naive,
I'm lazy. I picked the So you can now
poke holes in it. So what's with Andre
Wine and Todd Hunter? What is the reason
they trade
Samita really low growth so they trade
Hansen looks interesting, right? It has
high growth, but it has it's a highest
risk company, right? This is the problem
with storytelling. They look cheap, but
there's a really good reason they're
cheap. With Andre Wine and Todd Hunter,
the reason is really low
growth and with Hansen, it's really high
risk. Not no not much place to go,
right? And this is the problem with
storytelling and pricing is if you have
an agenda, you're going to find a way to
spin the story and say it's okay or you
know, you can make these companies
cheap, expensive, whatever you want them
to do.
So, I get fired as the beverage analyst
because of a sloppy job I did. I land on
my feet. I'm now the telecom
analyst in the late
'9s. I can also move in a time machine
across time. That's the way I get
rehired. And to give you a sense of the
telecom business before the
1990s, publicly traded telecom companies
were almost entirely in the US. You know
why? Because outside the US, the telecom
businesses were owned by governments
across much of the world. That started
to change in the 1980s. You started to
see them privatized. They became
publicly traded companies. So this is
1990s and I've looked at telecom
companies and I'm looking at ADRs. You
know what ADRs are? Foreign companies
list in the US. The advantage of looking
at PE ratios based in ADRs is at least
in theory all your earnings would were
required to be restated using gap
numbers. So the earning should be
comparable. So here again I'm going to
play the role of an IV analyst. I have
only one tool in my arsenal which is
what I can compare PE ratios. I'm really
good at that. I can find low numbers and
high numbers. Incredible skill. And I
come back with two by recommendations.
Telerass and Indoat. For those of you
who've never heard the company names,
Telerass in the late '9s was the
monopoly telecom company for Brazil.
It's since been broken up into seven
telecom companies. So, it was a
Brazilian telecom company.
Indats was the
Indonesian telecom company and Indonesia
in the late '9s was a very risky country
to be in because 96 had a complete
meltdown. I'm laying the foundation for
you to poke holes. So, these stocks
could be cheap, but Yara, what else
could explain why they trade a low PE
ratio? High risk. They're in risky
emerging because if you look at that
list some are emerging market telecom
companies and some are developed market
the German and the Danish telecom
company in there. So one could be high
risk Sophia. What's the other?
They have relatively low growth. This
time I'm not going to tell stories
because I'm going to spin myself into a
corner. So I open up my statistics book
to the multiple regression chapter. What
am I trying to explain? differences in
PE ratios across these companies. So
that becomes my dependent variable. What
are the two things that worry me?
Growth. So I put in the growth rate and
the other is risk. And I'm going to use
a very
generic proxy for risk. You know what a
dummy variable is in statistics? Takes
on a value one or zero. You do it to
capture something that splits the
sample.
So dummy variable of New York City
baseball fans will be Yankee fans, Mets
fans, 01. No, I I'll put the Mets fans
as zeros and the Yankee fans as ones
because that's my prior bias, but just
to separate the two. So here I created a
dummy variable where if you're a
developed market telecom company, I put
in a zero and if you're an emerging
market telecom company, I put a one. And
then I ran the regression. The R squ
that I got was 66%. Remember last
session what I said about R squ. 66% is
a pretty good R squ. I'm okay with
that. Let's see if the the the the
variables have the right science. Every
1% increase in growth increases my PE
ratio by 1.21. So if you're a telecom
company with a growth rate 5% higher
than mine, your PE ratio should be
roughly six. Five times 1.21 higher than
mine.
But if you're an emerging market telecom
company, so let's say have two telecom
companies, they have the exact same
growth rate. The emerging market telecom
company will have a P ratio 13.85 lower
than the developed market telecom
company. Remember when we did discarded
cash flow valuation, the way we
penalized risky countries is we pushed
up their cost of
capital. This is the market's way of
doing it. It does it through the
multiple. As for the intercept, all it
tells you is the level of the multiple
in that sector. It's the starting
point. Final check, you check for the t
statistics. We talked about the the the
tip off point above two. They're all
statistically
significant. I'm ready to launch. I can
take this regression and remember the
two companies, Indoat and Telerass.
Let's take and plug in Telerass's growth
rate and the fact that it's an emerging
market company. the regression I get a
predicted P for telebrass of 8.35%. How
would I describe that? If you're trying
to explain this to a non-statistics
person, the way you'd explain it is
given how telecom companies are priced
and given Telra's low growth and high
risk, this is what the PE ratio should
be. It's a conditional
pricing. It's actually trading at 8.9
times earnings.
It is actually overvalued, not
undervalued. Even though its P ratio
looks low, after you control for the low
growth and the high risk, it becomes
overvalued. The advantage of statistics
is it allows you to break through the
storytelling. Say, okay, you have lower
growth, it's okay, you have higher risk.
How does that play out as a predicted
value? Any questions on that example?
So, basically, I'm just looking across
the sample. Now, the one thing though is
if you have a sample size of four or
five, remember that small sample you
chose, you can't do this. You cannot use
statistics unless you get your sample to
enough of a size for you to be able to
run regressions. My usual rule is you
need a sample size of at least 10 to to
have one independent variable. You need
a sample size of at least 20 to get to
two independent variables. I'm just I
mean, you're saying why 10? Could be 12
and 24, but you need enough numbers in
there. If you take a sample size of 12,
for God's sakes, don't throw four
independent variables in there. It'll
break your statistics package down. Your
regression will start to give you
nonsense. So, the advantage of larger
sample size, you can control for more
things. So, I get fired as the telecom
analyst. I move forward in time. I'm now
the European banking analyst. I'm very
very So, you know, and now I've learned
a new pricing multiple. The P didn't
work for me in my last two jobs. I got
fired. Now I'm going to use price to
book. And with banks, actually, priceto
book ratios have
heft. Book value for equity at a bank
has more meaning than book value for
equity at pretty much any other company.
Why is that? Why is book value for
equity for a bank more
meaningful? One is book value of equity
is a number you can't mess with because
it's it drives what? But what goes into
the book value of equity for a bank?
What are the assets of a bank?
It's financial assets, right? Loans,
which should be easier to price than
some, you know, factory that makes
something. And what else is true about
bank accounting? That's been true, you
know, well before
2008. It's a one segment where
marktomarket has been the rule all the
way through. So book value of equity for
a bank first is because of the
regulatory capital restrictions. You
can't mess with it. Traditional
companies, you can make your book value
of equity go negative. Home Depot spent
three years with negative book equity
while its market cap r kept rising
because it bought back a lot of stock.
Banks can't do that. Second, because
it's financial assets, you should be
able to put a number on it better and
it's mark to market. So price to book
makes sense. And I'm the analyst now.
And here again I'm going to fall back on
a very simp. So I came up with a new
multiple but I still use the same way to
pick cheap stocks. I go pick you know
buyer rishi hypo. No that's I can't even
read the German there. Let's go to
commerce bank. Why? Because they have
low price to book ratios. In fact you
could argue and people argue that if a
stock trades at less than book value has
to be cheap. What's the implicit
assumption about book value that leads
people to that
conclusion? Anybody? When you say a
stock that trades at below book value,
it must be cheap. What are you
implicitly assuming about book
value? It's a story that they're
saying the book value can be you didn't
try. I was going to say that it's not a
true but you could liquidate it. The
assumption is book value is what you
will get if you liquidate the company.
That's implicit in a lot of thinking of
old-time value investors that and that
might have been true at some point in
time when you had lots of physical
assets you could sell but what exactly
would I get if I liquidated Weight
Watchers Weight Watchers in the verge of
distress right what am I going to
sell what would I get if I liquidated
Meta or Apple I mean these are not
companies with physical assets
Book value is kind of meaningless from
that perspective. Yeah.
That's a good point. Right. So in 2008,
why weren't we able to sell at market
value? Because a market value itself is
a shifting number, right? Market value
last Wednesday that I marked to market
would be very different than the mark
tomarket I got yesterday. It's like
trying to catch a falling knife. So you
might have started but okay that's
cheap. I can liquidate. You got tried to
liquidate in a falling market.
Everything is falling with
you. But this is price to book. And
remember the companion variable price to
book is return equity. There's the
return equity. And do you see a pattern
here? This banks at the lowest price to
book for the most part have the lowest
returns in equity. Banks that trade at
the highest price to book have the
highest return on equity. Until 2008, I
used to stop there with banks. I would
stop with the return equity saying risk
at a bank. How different can it be? the
regulators will keep you from becoming a
risky bank. Those days are done. So,
I've added a third column with a measure
of risk. And in hindsight, I wish I'd
used a different measure. I'm going to
ask you what that measure might have
been. I looked at the standard deviation
equity as a rough measure of
risk. So, before we get even deep dig
deeper here, what's the perfect
combination you'd like to find as an
investor? You want low price to book
bank. Want a low price to book bank. We
want a really high return equity and low
standard deviation. Everybody agree with
that? Low price to book, high return
equity, low standard deviation. Now, if
I eyeballing this data, is there a way I
could convert this rule into
practice? See this median number that
I've computed? What's the definition of
a median? Half of all companies have
numbers higher than this and half of all
on each of those variables. What if I
went looking for stocks that have a
price to book ratio lower than the
median? So I'm not making up a number.
So I'm arbitrary number lower than the
median. Have returns in equity higher
than the median and standard deviations
lower than the median. So let's see if
there's any. So basically you're looking
for price to book ratios lower than the
median. Right? So everything below 2.07.
So it's all the way through society
general with returns in equity higher
than the median. The median is 11.82.
Oh, there's one there. I'm close, right?
Bank Pariba is lower than the median,
higher. But then you look at the
standard deviation. It's 21.93. Standard
deviation is higher. So I got so close.
I got two out of
three. Why should that surprise you?
You're not going to get slam dunks in
this. But you're trying. You're trying
to see if you can get that all three
X's, right? Low price to book. Two years
ago when Silicon Valley Bank melted
down, I looked at the 50 largest US
banks and I went through this process.
Looked at price to book, looked at
return equity and I actually colorcoded
the numbers. So if the number was lower
than the median, I put, you know, price
to book, I made it green. If the return
equity was higher than the median, I
made it green. And for the risk, instead
of using the standard deviation in stock
prices, I used a measure of risk that I
think is more native to banking. number
you tend to think about when you think
about a risky bank. What is it that
makes a bank risky?
You could, but it's messy, right?
Because that's going to be really messy
because it depends on who you're lending
to
and but when you say risky bank, what is
it, Lisa? You want to
try? You could try that as well. But
again, is short better than long? I'm
not sure. Again, right? Because if you
mismatch, you could look for
mismatches. Default, you could look at
default risk. But again, I want
something when people talk about a bank
being risky, what do
they regulatory capital ratios and under
capitalized bank is viewed as riskier
than an over capitalized bank. So I
brought in tier one capital ratios. So
here's the mismatch I'm looking for. I
want a low price to book. I want a high
return equity. And I want a regulatory
capital
ratio that's much better than expected,
right? Higher than the average. There
wasn't a single one of the 50 banks that
met all three
criteria. The bank that got closest was
City. I'll tell you the two measures
where they came in well. They had among
the lowest price to book ratios. They
traded.7 times book value. That was
good. Their return equity was actually
not bad. It was mildly, you
know, oh, I'm sorry. Their tier one
capital ratio was really good. Their
return in equity though was 9.7% which
was lower than the median by about
1%. So it got really close. Take a bank
like JP Morgan trades well above price
to book. So it's a red has return equity
above. That's green and capital ratio is
pretty good. You're looking for three
out of three. There wasn't a single bank
that came in. Yeah. Even if you don't
hit three out of three, I mean, is there
still value if you have two out of
three?
There's a better way to do this, right?
Because this is the problem. Looking for
those checks, you're going to very
quickly run in. So, finally, I said,
"Hey, finding all three is going to be
impossible to do." So, I'm going to fall
back on an old trick. Run the regression
of price to book against return, equity,
and standard deviation. Again, let's
measure the regression. R square of 79%.
That looks pretty good to me. I can live
with that.
Are the signs on the coefficients the
right ones? Higher return equity
companies of higher price to book? Yes,
that makes sense. Higher risk companies
of lower price to book. Again, okay. Do
the t statistics meet my requirements?
Yes, they're both above two. That price
to book ratio regression can be used to
get a predicted price to book ratio for
every bank on that
sample. Now I don't have to worry about
two out of three, three. The numbers
take care of it. And that's again the
advantage of the regression because when
we do the median thing, we're
eyeballing. That's basically we're
trying to find the cheap stock by just
looking at the number and the human mind
can't deal with all of that data. So
we'll use the median to make that
judgment. In fact, I use this regression
to get predicted price to book ratios.
So if you take buyer rishi hypo, its
price to book is 08. But after I factor
in the low return equity, it's predicted
price to book is 89. It is undervalued
by about 10.6%.
6%. So with each bank, I come up with a
predicted price to book ratio based on
the banking regression and its
variables. When you run this regression
though, assuming you get to a sample of
25 or 30. Couple of notes of caution. In
this case, when I looked at the
coefficient, do they have the right
sign? They did, right? Is that always
going to happen? No. You might run a
regression where return in equity not
only is a wrong sign but it's
statistically significant. See that
doesn't make sense. Here's what you
cannot do. You can't take your pencil
and draw a line through the minus and
now everything looks okay. It looks like
a plus. The data is the data pricing.
You've already entered this arena and
saying I am going to let the markets
tell me how much to pay. That's a whole
pricing game, right? And if the market
is doing something senseless, guess
what? You got to build that senseless
thing into your pricing and saying that
doesn't make sense, but I am in the
pricing arena, not in intrinsic
valuation. Could you run a regression
and nothing is significant?
Yes, it's not your fault. The reason I'm
trying to preempt the set of emails I'm
going to get in the last two weeks from
you is I've run a regression. Nothing
works. What can make it work? The answer
is the data is the data. You can expand
your sample, try to bring in another
variable. The end of the process, you
might conclude that I can't explain any
of the differences in this multiple
across this sector. In which case, you
just compare to the average and move on
saying nothing else you could do,
nothing for a better prediction. Yeah.
When we look at sectors that are not
like the oil past where there's a lot of
comparable firms at what point are the
uh comparables that you look at too
broad the data the regression takes care
of itself right there's nothing but
that's the advantression you don't have
to draw an arbitrary line in fact let's
say in the oil and gas sector right is
Claire here no she's not as I was going
to call oh there you are let's take the
oil and gas sector you're sitting in a
different row that's why I didn't catch
you so so in the oil and gas sector
Let's What's a multiple you think makes
the most sense?
I'll let you decide. Enterprise value
per barrel of oil, enterprise value to
EIDA, enterprise value to
revenue of mult of EIDA. Yeah. Okay. So,
you're going to need let's let's say we
decide to go with the EV to EIDA
multiple. Let's look at the variables
you want to control for. Differences in
tax rates probably not an issue because
you're probably looking at U. Let's say
you look at if you're bringing in global
oil companies, you probably should
control for difference in tax rates.
Aramco pays a very different tax rate
than Exxon Mobile. So, you know, will
returns on capital vary across oil
companies? They will. You know what it
will depend on? What the cost of
extracting? So, if you're in high cost
areas to get the oil out, you'll
probably earn lower margins and lower
returns in capital than an oil company
that has lower cost reserves, right? So
you probably want to control for
that. Will you want to control for
differences in reserves across
companies? I would expect companies with
a lot more undeveloped reserves to trade
at a higher multiple than companies
without capital like you actually lets
you download the reserves and barrels of
oil by company. You're essentially going
to control for the things you would ask
as an individual if you're going to buy
an oil company, right? Which is, hey,
you know, how much does it cost you to
extract the oil? How many barrels of oil
do you have in your reserves? And try to
bring those into your numbers to make
that judgment of is this company cheap
or expensive. The advantage with oil
companies again is the sample size is so
big that you could bring in criteria and
still end up with a big enough sample.
Software companies the same
way. There are enough entertainment
software companies that you can look at
just entertainment software companies
and get literally hundreds of companies
in your sample.
And the advantage of having S&P Capital
IQ is that you know last Friday when I
screen for public first screen for
publicly traded companies because S&P
Capital IQ also carries private business
data. Why can't we use private business
data and pricing not publicly traded
public traded therefore there's no
market pricing numerator and a multiple
is a market price right market cap. So
if it's not traded it shouldn't be in
your sample. So, first I screened for
publicly traded companies. I came up
with I think
61,000. Then I ran a second screen that
I've learned to run before I use Capital
IQ. I said, "Find me all the companies
that are publicly traded with a market
cap greater than zero." For some reason,
there are 12,000 publicly traded
companies with a market cap of zero. I
don't even know where they trade or what
the trading even means. They're probably
these companies got listed,
incorporated, never got traded. I ended
up with 49,000 publicly traded companies
with the market price. I'm off to the
races, right? You tell me what you want
to price. I will find a large enough
sample for you to do it. In some cases,
I can add a lot of criteria and still
end up with enough of a sample. In other
cases, I might have to be a little
looser about what I and that all
presupposes that I want a large sample
where I can ask these questions about
what do I control.
Let's stay on the price to book example
because one of the things I do at the
start of the every year, it's kind of a
fun exercise and you're welcome to try
it as well. It takes about 10 minutes to
do is to download the price to book
ratios of the 100 largest market cap
companies in the US, you know, and you
and you're free to do it. 100 largest in
whatever country you're in. You can do
it globally. I take the price to book
ratios and the returns of equity of
these companies and then I do a scatter
plot. You know remember scatter plots
from statistics. There's a scatter plot
and this is in January 2010. So each of
these points is a company. The way a
scatter plot works is you take each
company you take the combination of
price to book and return equity and you
plot them. So if you want you should
count those. There should be a 100
bubbles in
there. You're saying what the heck am I
going to do with this? If you have a
scatter plot, you know what a regression
line is, right? It's that best fit line
through the scatter plot. That's what a
regression line
is. How does the computer find that best
fit line? Do you remember statistics?
How does that best fit line get fit? Why
is it? OS, which is you minimize the
squared distances from the line. You
know how the Greeks came up with
regressions? They actually measured each
distance. Thank god we're not in those
times. can imagine standing, you know,
sitting there with a ruler saying,
"Let's measure each." But that's
basically minimize the square distances.
That's why it's called OS
regression. There's the best fit line
right there. Okay? You say, "What are
these two other lines?" When you run a
regression and you get an R squ that's
not 100%, what do you get? You get a
range around your prediction. That's a
90%
range. What are all these dots that are
between the two lines? Those are the
companies that I cannot reject the
hypothesis that they're close to fairly
priced because they fall between. So the
only companies I'm focused on the
companies that fall above the line, the
top line and below the bottom line. So
help me out dear. Which one of these
companies is overpriced and which ones
are
underpriced? Go
ahead. The bottom are underpriced in
this case. We'll come back to measure
those through. The companies that fall
above the top line are overpriced. Let's
look at the three that stuck out in
2010. Google, Infosys, and
Gilead. You're not familiar with the
companies. I save you the trouble of
what they shared in common. They were
high growth companies. And already you
can see why this scatter plot might be a
little misleading because it compares
price to book to return equity, but it
doesn't control for differences in
growth and risk. And some of the higher
growth companies look
overpriced, but once you bring in the
growth, they come back into line. You
look at the three underpriced companies.
CO does anybody know what COP stands
for? It's corn
Phillips. XO M is Exon Mobile. So two of
your three underpriced are companies.
And already that should make you a
little
suspicious. Why did they look
underpriced? And the reason was the oil
prices had dropped since the most recent
year and they looked underpriced because
their trailing 12 month earnings
reflected the higher. You see, if you
could explain this all away, what's the
point of doing it? Hey, these are the
100 largest market cap stocks in in in
the US. You're not going to see any
obvious huge mispricing there because
it's not like they're being they can be
ignored, right? Hundreds of analysts
track them. But it's a good starting
point for looking for mismatches because
one of the first things I did and don't
let this make you dizzy, you know, you
can do a three-dimensional scatter plot.
I hate them because I don't know whether
I'm coming or going or where I am in
this graph, you know, where I took price
to book return equity and expected
growth rate. And when I did that, Google
Infosys and Gilead dropped back to the
line because now I brought in growth. If
I was worried about risk, I could bring
in the regression beta or standard
deviation. Again, much of the
differences can go away. Your objective
is not to explain away the differences,
but to see if there's something that
still sticks out after you control for
the differences.
Question forward.
You could, but each one carries its own
dem its own measures, right? You could
do forward earnings that will take care
of the Exxon Mobile Conor Phillip. But
then there might be other things you
bring in with a forward earnings that
create its own noise. So everything's a
trade-off. So that's one reason you
might use price to forward earnings is
to prevent something like
that. So because I had this data again,
I fell back. But now you can see
whenever the pictures don't work, I go
back to a multiple regression because
multiple regression allows me to work
through across 100 companies, the R
squared was 67%. Think about it. 67% of
the variation in price to book ratios
across a 100 largest market cap stocks
can be
explained by the return equity growth in
beta. These
statistics I might as well take beta
out. Doesn't really help. So if I reran
this regression, I'd probably run it
with just growth and and roe and then I
can use it to get an expected price for
every one of the 100 company. That
couldn't be a oneperson hedge
fund. Use a regression. You get the most
underpriced, the most overpriced, and
play it out. You're a hedge fund. What
do you do? You buy the most underpriced.
You sell the most overpriced. Have you
made any money yet? You know, you get
down on your knees and please God, let
them move to the regression line because
if they do, you're going to make money
on both sides. You went to quant
investing. Quantum investing is just
what I did at a very simplistic level
carried to more rich richer data and
more powerful statistical techniques,
right? Because this is OS simple
regression which is price to book return
equity data. But if you think about all
of the data we can collect and all of
the powerful statistical tools, it's
just this carried to the next step
saying, "Hey, that's how we're hoping."
But they're all built on that same
premise. You're pricing stocks, you're
not valuing them, and you're hoping they
move back towards that middle that you
predicted. So, here's the update.
January
2025, start of this year, I took the 100
largest market cap stocks, put them in
there, drew the regression line. Quite a
few above that line, right? Let's see if
you recognize any of the names there.
There's Eli Liy. What made Ela Lily
suddenly surge in price?
They among the big pharma companies,
they're the ones who are furthest ahead
on the obesity drugs. They're the ones
that most likely to displace Novo
Nordisk with the drugs. They got priced
up, but they're looking expensive. Maybe
the growth from the obesity drugs. I
mean, there's uh Nvidia is there
somewhere just barely above the line.
There's Palanteer. No surprise most
snowflake. Basically, these are
companies where you can say, "Hey,
there's growth there." But it could also
be that they're overpriced. In fact,
I'll wager if you look at the punishment
that's happened this year and you look
at the stocks that are above the line,
many of them have moved towards the top
line, if not into the
zone. The mo the stock that the only
stock that actually came out as
underpric was it was Oracle. I know
somebody's doing Oracle. It's a bit of a
puzzle why they're priced so low, but
it's it's it's in there. Maybe it's the
thread of AI coming for them. It could
be any of those dimensions. Looks
underpriced. I'm not a pricer. I don't
trade things, but to me, this is a good
place to start to see if something
sticks out, right? So, you can do price
to book versus return equity. You can
add a third dimension if you want. I
always prefer to start with the picture
before I run the regression because it's
better, I think, visually to see where
companies fall and then say, can I
explain that
away? Since we're talking about analyst,
I've got fired at multiple
places. My final landing spot is I'm now
the trucking
analyst. Talk about a sector you don't
want to become an
analyst. The multiple news is EV dab dab
and I'm going to put out a buy
recommendation. I'd have made it KLLM
but I'd never heard of the company. I'm
too lazy to find them. But I've heard of
Ryder Systems partly because as I've
been driving around town I've been
seeing rider
trucks. Why am I recommending them?
Because they trade at a multiple of 2.8
times
every so on writer
systems. This is actually an actual buy
at the time. I pulled it out and now
I it could be cheap, right? But ask me
the questions you would need to ask
before you decide that rider systems is
cheap. What are some of the things we
said we need to control for when you do
EVITA? Yeah.
What were their margins like or returns
on capital? Because margins it's not an
EV to sales, right? EV to sales you ask
margin EV to EITA. Let's start with the
tax rate, right? Is there a tax
difference here?
Maybe all the other country companies
have NOLs that are carried forward. I
checked there was no real difference.
The tax rates seem to be roughly the
same. So that's one thing off the table.
What's the next one you're going to ask
about returns on capital, right? Maybe
you know writer systems has terrible
returns on capital and everybody else,
it turns out this is a terrible sector
to begin with. Everybody earns pretty
much low substandard returns on capital.
So that's not the issue. So that's off
the table. What
else? Growth. They're all mature
businesses, low
growth. Check their cost of capital.
Maybe half the companies are in emerging
markets. No, they're all US
companies. I'm almost there, right? The
one question that I could not cleanly
answer is this is the trucking business.
You know how reinvestment works in this
business? You replace your entire fleet
every five, six, seven years. Why do you
replace your entire fleet? You get much
better discount price if you do the
whole thing at one go. If I were to add
a column to this table, what is that?
What data item would you like? How old
are these fleets? Right? I can't tell
you yours too because that's a
management judgment, but I can tell you
how. And that was public data. I pulled
up that extra data item. And guess what?
Ryder Systems had the oldest fleet or
the youngest
fleet. They had the oldest fleet.
another reinvestment was just around the
corner. You can almost see this play
out, right? You go buy rider systems
because it looks
cheap. A month later or two months
later, you're going to wake up to a new
story. You know what the news story is
going to say? They've had to issue a
billion or two billion in debt or equity
to buy new trucks and there goes your
cheap EVA overnight.
My problem as I said with pricing is not
that people do it but that the equity
research analyst would put the buy and
write systems hadn't bothered to even
check the data item and ask could that
be the reason they went low
EVA just basic questioning would have
brought out hey this is the the oldest
fleet am I factor you if you factor in
and say in spite of it I think it's
cheap then I'm okay with it but you need
to ask and answer that
question the oldest fleet not inspirated
happens in two months then all of a
sudden you can repeat reward.
What's the reward going to be though?
Your price is not going to go up. It's
new equity issue. You're going to get
diluted like crazy. Your stock price is
actually going to go down. Your EVID
would recover, right? Because your
numerator gets larger. But you as a
stock investor don't get any benefits
from doing that. You actually end up
with a lower equity value. So from a
perspective of an investor, the EV to
Ebida recovering doesn't help you
because it's not your multiple. that's
going up. It's basically the the
delusion effect that's kicking
in. So it's it's basically asking that
question that's so let's throw let's
suppose you're comparing let's say
airlines right it's a mess first what
multiple are you going to use enterprise
value or equity
value remember with the equity multiples
you need equity earnings. So if you have
a business where a lot of companies lose
money, you probably want to steer away
from equity multiples. So you're going
to go with enterprise value
multiples. The question you face is
enterprise value to sales, enterprise
value to know EBIT DA, enterprise value
to EBIT. What do you think?
Or maybe passengers flown, right? I
mean, in a sense, open the door. There
are lots of different variants you might
decide to use
here. And to control for across
airlines, what are some of the things
you want to control for?
What do you collect for the the the
rates at which you fill up your flights
might be a factor. How old your aircraft
are might be a factor because you might
have to replace
them. Tax rates, if you're comparing US
airlines, but if you're comparing
airlines across the world, you compare
for differences in tax rates. Be
creative, right? When you think about
risk, your risk measure doesn't have to
be a beta or something that came out of
intrinsic value. It can be something
very specific to pricing in the sector
you're looking at.
Do one final example and we'll end for
the day.
The only business that's even more
boring than the trucking business is the
grocery
business. For a long time, the business
when nothing happened, margins were low,
growth rates were low. So you're
comparing, you know, company after
company all at the same until in 2007,
there was a new kid in town that kind of
broke the mold. And grocery analysts
didn't know what to do with this new
company, company called Whole Foods,
right? Grocery business with higher
margins going after at that time at
least a niche market. And when Whole
Foods came out in 2007, I did a price
basically I did a scatter plot of
grocery stores and I threw Whole Foods
in and you can see the outlier right
there. It looks hopelessly
overpriced. People are still putting buy
recommendations on it. Why? They said
the margins are higher which was
technically true. At that time when I
ran the regression though even with the
higher margins my predicted price to
sales ratio was 043. It was trading at
1.41 times revenues. looks dramatically
overpriced. That was
2007. This is 2009, two years later.
Same sector. See where whole foods
is? It's gone from being up above there
to almost the most underpriced company
in the
sector. So it went from hugely
overpriced to hugely underpriced. I did
a predicted price to sales.36 was
trading at 31. It went from being very
expensive, one of the cheapest grocery
stocks. Yes.
2010. It's tough to find it, but Whole
Foods now falls right on the line
somewhere, right? Or just above the
line. So, it's gone from being
underpriced to again
overpriced. There's a story here because
by
2011, Whole Foods was on the on the
line.
For four years, Whole Foods went from
being overpriced to underpriced to
overpriced because analysts didn't quite
have a handle on it. And once they
figured it out, Whole Foods settled it,
but it took four years for the market to
figure it
out. You come to
2015, there's Sprouts. You know, the
line should go up there. Up there again,
a company that analysts couldn't quite
figure out, a small growing grocery
store chain. The point I'm trying to
make is when you get a new company in a
sector that doesn't look like any of the
existing companies, it takes a while for
analysts to figure out even what to do
with it. And that's your chance in
intrinsic value. That's when markets
make mistakes. Yeah.
The analyst is every grocery store you
trade.3.4 times revenues. They're all
low margin businesses. When you get a
company that has a high margin, you've
never seen anything like this in the
grocery business. They don't even have
the because they don't run regressions,
right? The way you do this, you compare
EV to sales across companies say, "What
do I do about this company that doesn't
look like any of my other
companies?" Analysts when when Tesla
came in, that is exactly the problem
they ran into, right? They've never seen
some like something like this in the
automobile company. 15 years later, they
still struggle with Tesla because it
doesn't look like a legacy auto
company. Sometimes when you get a new
company in a business that kind of
disrupts the Airbnb in the hospitality
business, nobody has any idea how to
price the company rel. They don't even
know what to price it
against. So, it takes a while for
investors to learn about a company,
especially if it's very different from
the traditional companies in a business.
And that's your chance and my chance as
investors. Yes. Think sprouts still
without it's now back down. So basically
you can see that was 2015. You look at
sprouts in 2025. People have kind of
soured on sprouts. It's come back to the
line. So eventually they worked their
way back to the process because you know
it's Sprouts when it came out it had it
had regional issues because wasn't a
national chain. It had these growth
issues and margin factors things that
made it very different from a
traditional grocery business. Right? And
you're going to see that play
out. So I'm going to if you want to
start your pricing, you have everything
you need to start your pricing. So at
least how many of you have not used S
SNP Capital IQ yet in this
class. You're not going to admit to it
even if you haven't. You should though
because it for the pricing part, it'll
help you a great deal. It's you can live
without it, but it'll make your life a
lot easier if you use it for the
pricing.
Oh yeah, I think